they left the door open again
he snuck in he snuck in we have Maurice
Ashley in the house Maurice uh tell us a
little bit about the U.S chess
championships what is your opinion on
that well you know it's first of all
it's been fun being here hanging out
with everybody getting to see you all uh
going to dinners with Rex and the like
and getting into arguments with the
arena crushing the whole thing it's been
great the U.S championship of course is
the Premier championship in the world we
have the the best average players at the
high level however uh you know you got
to wonder about the youth movement here
because we're seeing somebody like I
wonder who did really well but he's in
college he's a college student he's a
he's talking like oh I'm just trying to
keep things simple and not blunder you
wonder how much he might stay in chess
eventually you want to see that happen
with somebody that talented really
pursue it we've been waiting for that
breakthrough from from Jeffrey Zhang for
a while he's been at that 2700 custom
he's kind of kind of plateaued there a
little bit it and we're hoping to see
him take that next step so we really
have to to hope for more I think because
the average the average age is a little
bit High I mean the average age of our
top five players I I took a look is 34.4
that's the average age of our top five
players and for India the average age of
the top five players including Anand
who's 52 years old is 30 years old so
that's that's significant the youth
movement has has to come and we need to
see the youngsters start to thrive and
we're definitely seeing a very talented
crop of players right now you have Sam
Savion Jeffrey Sean a Wonder as you were
mentioning Hans Neiman as well there's
something about this last few rounds the
tension is building up and we start
seeing blunders and things of that
nature from your experience as a
commentator is that natural I think so I
think that I actually I think it's more
so though the length of this tournament
we haven't had 13 Rounds in a while and
the players are definitely feeling the
fatigue the tension the importance of
the last few rounds you see The Savvy
vets like Fabi who say I don't just
chill out in the end and not do anything
crazy and take those drawers and let Rey
suffer as he tries to catch me so I
think that's smart uh but you also see
somebody like like Wesley Saul who
didn't start out that well but give him
more time the weight starts to come in
and the big dog shows that he's got real
teeth but I I do think the length has
been critical to the tournament you
mentioned those young players in
particular I see I think you only see
the real emergence of Hans Neiman I mean
for for various reasons he has become a
lightning rod of attention I wonder I'm
not really sure what his intentar like I
said it really looks like he's he's bent
on being a student he really wants I
mean he wants to diversify it's clear
get a college degree always nice to have
something to fall back on and also to
expand yourself as a person I think
Jeffrey and Sam they Sam Savion I mean
they've been there they've been there
for a while we've seen them around this
is not their first rodeo no and we
really need to
we don't need to put any additional
pressure on them but we really need to
see more if we're going to uh have see
them carry that mantle into the Next
Generation in the next few years
speaking of uh Sam Seville and I'm sure
you will love to talk about this
situation did you see what happened
yesterday with the decapitation of the
king it's rare we get to say those words
in chess I mean you know I would have
really pumped that one up if I was doing
this broadcast I mean come on whoever
sees a guy grab the opponent's gate and
then rip the top off yeah okay you
didn't quite rip it off I was like dude
my king no take it then you want it you
can have it wow I'd have been in
absolute shock you tried that in
Brooklyn and see what happened let's go
glue it let's go through it bro bro
seriously where's the referee you better
come get this guy fix the situation that
was absolutely hilarious never seen
anything like it and I don't think we're
going to see anything like it for a long
time to come no I don't think so either
guys any questions yes well Anastasia
you first I've got like five just a
second I've been writing go on okay no I
just have one comment like every time
Maurice comes to the city to the town
something happens
[Laughter]
yes I don't know what's going on here
but it's clear that it's good maybe
there is some connection Maurice come on
let's face it the U.S Championship the
creme de La Creme of the United States
very respectable tournament and somehow
we got on this wrong track and it it's
crazy what what why why what what
happened I mean it's something strange
going on I don't know what to tell you I
mean it does seem as though after what
happened with with Hans uh it's all
going off the rails everybody is
sensitive I mean remember you made a
mistake take in your comments in your
commentary doing one of the games where
castling was illegal right it was a
hilarious moment you know it was fun yes
it was just all in good fun so I decided
to post about it uh who they let this
guy they actually paid this guy for GM
commentary right and of course this guy
is like one of my best friends so no big
deal take it in stride man the number of
people who got on your side and and
thought that I was a supreme jerk
thinking a joke about my my good buddy
it's like people I think the apology
[Laughter]
condescending to your fellow commentator
yeah no he's Christian get out of here
we've been having a lot of fun and
there's a lot of misinterpretation of a
lot of things that are happening here
absolutely even when even when good
friends are are having so I'm curious as
to that sensitivity I'm wondering if
it's real sensitivity or is it people
feel that they need to just simply be
obnoxious
or amplify you know a little thing
happens and all of a sudden it turns
into a conflagration and you're like
whoa what happened here I just think
it's the age we live in look we had a
lot of fun here in the studio and I said
the Asura and Anastasia were having a
lot of fun and a lot of laughs as well
even everybody all the viewers notice
how much respect they had from my
colleagues here yes okay now I gotta
jump in Marie so you know you watched
the whole videotape right and the whole
the king and the the cross and here you
can have your king
then Hans comes in and he explains what
was said oh your cross let's go glue it
come on together we can leave and we can
go blue I mean I don't know if you lip
read but boy that was not my
interpretation of that conversation
is that the way you saw it as well let's
have a friendly discussion no no no no
no that wasn't friendly at all he's not
I mean Hansen's been living in New York
for a couple of years New Yorkers don't
talk like that you're in Brooklyn you
just grabbed my cake bro like what you
doing right I'm gonna be fighting words
right there uh fight you know that
there's no way and you saw him looking
at him like he was just break Ray
there's no way in the world they were
they were being genteel the gently let's
go glue the king please no no no no look
at that look bro what are you doing
right right that was just uh wow so uh
have you ever had this kind of fights
over the chess board or because of
something what happened on the
chessboard I mean not you but maybe
we've seen it I'm a lover not a fight
like no I I'm never had a fight although
I have seen stuff happen at the board
and certain kind of language which we
cannot have on this air right absolutely
has happened uh growing up like I said
in BK
um
you know people get heated people get
emotional and the trash talking starts
and you know but I've never seen a
decapitated
dancing take up your tickets right now I
mean Christian's gonna be dancing on the
dance floor no we don't want to see that
man don't dance
and dude I I got a discount for you it's
like I got a five percent discount
friends and family those 25 tickets yes
everybody can yeah you're so nice yeah
like I'm going out on the limb for a
year buddy I think I'm on the list I
think I'm okay okay good to see you
thank you for joining us Maurice thanks
guys I had enjoying uh the show
um what